Hi guys, it's Janna Danielson, the creator and super user of the Coachball.
Thank you so much for landing on this page and for just wanting to learn a little bit more about this little product.
What I can tell you about the Coachball is that I've been using it with clients and in my own body for the past decade plus.
The Coachball was really designed to work either in conjunction with your physiotherapist if you're doing pelvic floor physiotherapy
or just as prevention in your own body.
If you want to make sure that your hip range of motion stays active, if you want to make sure that your low back stays healthy, your posture stays healthy,
or maybe already are experiencing some of these issues.
You sneeze or cough a little bit and you know, wet your pants or there's pain during intercourse or just pelvic floor pain.
This little ball is actually quite magical.
All it takes is three minutes a day. You sit on the ball in a position that's most comfortable for you.
So it could be on your kitchen chair sitting on it in between the pubic bones and the anus.
It might be cross-legged on the floor. It could be on your couch so the couch takes a little bit of the kind of the brunt of the force of the ball.
Once we add diaphragmatic breathing to the equation, it really does become one of your very best tools in your health and wellness toolbox.
So all you need to do to find out more is just scroll through our page, the buy now button you will find this is going to become a very good friend.